[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Jean-Daniel Laval
directeur du Théâtre de fontelle Fleurie
bonjour bonjour votre salle de spectacle
est de cinéma sont en travaux depuis fin
2021 mais dès le début des travaux vous
avez mis en place des spectacles hors
les murs alors l'occasion de faire
découvrir d'autres lieux au spectateur
comment ont été choisis justement ces
lieux et est-ce que vous cherchez un
lien entre les spectacles et le lieu ah
oui absolument absolument
la difficulté des travaux c'est en soi
c'est pour aller vers le mieux donc on
va pas discuter ça en revanche ce qui
était compliqué c'est la perte du
contact avec le public en fait donc il
était nécessaire est vraiment important
pour nous de pouvoir conserver ce lien
en plus on a eu deux ans de covid avant
enfin voilà c'est très compliqué tout ça
donc on s'est dit ben on va balader des
spectacles dans les lieux différents et
pour répondre à la question oui quand on
a fait par exemple macadam Farmer on l'a
fait dans une grange un peu cliché mais
c'est vrai que c'était ça qui s'y
prêtait euh et là on a fait un Beckett
dans une bibliothèque on a fait un
Pagnol à la petite chapelle c'était
vraiment très très intime sur le plan du
son de il y avait 50 personnes on fait
des spectacles vraiment un peu intimiste
un petit peu comme le théâtre
d'appartement alors pour 50 70 en
dépasse pas 100 personnes et puis ça
nous a permis alors ça c'est le grand
avantage je parle par exemple du Beckett
la dernière bande qui est un extrait
difficile que jamais monté ça nous a
permis justement de prendre des risques
assez conséquents puisque jauge petite
et lieu insolite donc le côté
événementiel un peu et on a eu le
Beckett j'étais très surpris puisque les
20 places on a fait cinq reportations
mais on a eu ça les 100 personnes
c'était assez étonnant alors le théâtre
peut se jouer partout jusque non
seulement il peut mais il doit de mon
point de vue en plus je crois que là il
faut que vraiment les gens de la culture
que ce soit le ministère que ce soit les
soutiens responsables prennent
conscience que le public a vraiment
changé ça c'est une réalité on se voit
la face avec ça mais c'est une vraie
réalité les gens ont pris
[Musique]
du théâtre est une chose vers lequel on
tend parce que les gens ont besoin d'un
peu d'exceptionnel de rareté et une
autre réflexion sur les choses le texte
fait pas tout le sens fait pas tout ils
ont besoin de de ressentir je crois que
la perte de sens au sens sensoriel nous
coûte très cher aujourd'hui et alors les
travaux de votre salle devaient se
terminer en ce début d'année pardon
malheureusement ils ont pris du retard
et la programmation que vous aviez prévu
ne peut donc pas se faire mais qu'à cela
tienne si je peux me permettre vous
continuez quand même la programmation
hors les murs on va justement parler des
prochaines dates de spectacle et
événements que vous organisez donc en
dehors du théâtre de Fontenay-le-Fleury
vous avez annoncé sur votre site
internet que vous prépariez un spectacle
pour le mois de mars alors si je me
trompe pas c'est le 18 mars pouvez-vous
nous en dire un petit peu plus sur cette
date oui justement c'est la c'est la
quantité de ce qu'on est en train de
dire ça fait des années depuis 2005 que
je suis au théâtre de Fontenay-le-Fleury
de 1000 kushiotati que je que j'avais
repéré un lieu en face d'une maternelle
il y a une espèce de d'amphithéâtre grec
comme ça sur une grosse marche en pierre
que j'ai toujours trouvé magique et je
passais par là assez souvent pour
rentrer chez moi et je me suis quand
même j'adore faire quelque chose
là-dedans et ouais depuis 2005
j'adorerais faire quelque chose
j'adorerais faire puis on le fait pas on
est paresseux on est flemmards il y a
toujours des bonnes excuses pour pas
faire les choses ouais mais bon on est
dans un petit confort le théâtre marche
la salle est belle et ça en fait pas là
on est contraint on a plus de salle et
tout d'un coup je me dis mais ce lieu et
donc on va faire un spectacle formidable
qui est entrepris par des jeunes qui
viennent de l'école Jacques Lecoq qui
sont de plusieurs nationalités donc ils
sont beaucoup dans le gros mot ils sont
pas dans le texte ils sont dans le dans
le borborithme dans le langage inventé
un peu à la tatie Jacques Tati et il
faut un spectacle sur l'immigration et
ils m'ont dit ils ont vu ils m'ont dit
mais c'est super il faut le faire ici il
y a deux plateaux c'est il traverse une
rivière donc ça symbolise la rivière et
là on met presque 250 personnes sur ces
gradins et c'est tellement confiné un
peu à la grippe comme ça qu'on a même
pas besoin de sonoriser enfin ça va être
absolument magique j'y crois très très
fort et c'est pas assez la richesse et
des travaux du covid ça qui nous amène à
ces choses-là et bien le spectacle du
coup s'appelle traverser la rivière sous
la pluie c'est le 18 mars en espérant
qu'il ne pleuve pas évidemment
la pièce alors en mars également vous
avez prévu un parcours de théâtre au
jardin alors quel est l'intérêt de cet
événement et bien alors celui-là ne sera
pas
je suis désolé je ne sais pas si on peut
couper mais peu importe si on ne peut
pas couper il se frappe il se fera pas
parce qu'on s'est aperçu alors là en
revanche que c'est une autre
problématique c'est qu'on avait eu cette
ambition un peu comme fin d'une un peu
fin d'une saison un peu massacrée par
tous ces problèmes qui sont là on
voulait finir festive de façon festive
il y a eu d'autres projets qui sont
venus se mettre en place notamment le
projet dont on va certainement parler
à propos des Olympiades de la culture
l'isoler pardon oui ils appellent ça les
impacts de la culture donc comment ils
appellent ça les Olympiades il me semble
que c'est oui bref avec la mairie la
mairie nous a sollicité nous demander
nous fait appel à nous et on a dit les
dates cohabitent elles sont trop proches
on n'avait pas trop lancé le programme
des jardins qui est une idée qu'on
reprendra très certainement parce que je
la trouve vraiment très belle donc on
s'est branché là dessus et ça sera une
sorte de tennis impro c'est à dire que
la volonté que nous avons eu c'est un
projet que j'ai déjà fait par le passé
c'est de faire jouer vraiment tout le
monde tennis apro c'est une joute
quasiment oratoire sur un terrain de
tennis comme on se jette des balles on
se jette des mots il y a un arbitre sur
sa chaise et qui est un arbitre
protecteur c'est à dire que quand il
sent que
l'apprenti l'amateur qui s'est lancé
sans jamais avoir fait de tête de sa vie
quand il sent que il est en panne il va
lui trouver une faute il va lui trouver
une situation drôle pour le le sortir de
cette situation là donc et c'est 15-0 15
15-30 voilà ça peut c'est des joutes qui
durent 2 minutes 2 minutes 30 et donc on
commence au 16e de finale avec 32
concurrents qui vont et ses concurrents
c'est vous c'est c'est n'importe qui qui
s'inscrit et on va travailler autour de
sayakote à la fois sportif à la fois
culturel ben sportif parce que le sport
du cerveau il faut même c'est de
l'improvisation et très encadré très
soutenu c'est un projet qu'on a beaucoup
fait dans les entreprises et qui
fonctionne très très bien qui est très
drôle très convivial très festif et donc
cet événement c'est le premier avril
exactement et ça tombe très bien le
premier avril avec des thèmes de
poissons on va s'en sortir très très
bien alors on va poursuivre sur sur la
programmation avec ce que vous
définissez comme une folie musicale du
12 au 14 mai vous proposez le Beethoven
project l'idée est simple proposer
l'oeuvre complète des quatuores
Beethoven sur trois jours alors comment
va s'organiser cet événement et bien
pareil puisque nous n'avons toujours pas
de terre et donc en fait il faut savoir
que il y a 8h30 de quatuor ça dure à peu
près 8h30 et ça représente moi je dirais
une vingtaine de pièces qu'on appelle
des opus et donc il y a des opus qui
font 20 minutes il y a des opus qui font
45 minutes si on en met deux ça fait une
ans et demi donc l'idée c'est qu'on va
les balader dans des lieux donc l'église
la chapelle pareil le le petit théâtre
grec là la mairie pour l'ascenseur en
discussion mais elle devrait se rendre
disponible
l'extérieur le marché alors pas pendant
le marché mais dans le marché fermé
aux acheteurs et aux vendeurs mais le
lieu utilisé parce qu'il a une résonance
donc il y aura des opus de 20 minutes
qui seront gratuits pour donner envie
aux gens d'écouter de la musique
classique et peut-être leur donner envie
d'aller plus loin dans la rencontre avec
Beethoven et puis il y aura évidemment
des des parties de 45 minutes une heure
une heure et demie qui elles seront dans
le cadre d'un on sait pas encore on n'a
pas encore discuté mais enfin des tarifs
très accessibles en tout cas parce que
ce qu'on veut en fait les garçons qui
font ça qui est un quatuor léoniste qui
est vraiment très connu et assez
compétent dans le domaine de de cette
musique là ils font aussi du spectacle
burlesque c'est comme ça que je les ai
rencontrés
ils avaient ce rêve donc on est en train
de parler d'un rêve d'artiste d'aller au
plus loin de ce qu'ils peuvent faire et
une rencontre avec un public qui n'est
pas forcément à guéri donc l'argent ne
doit pas être un problème donc on va le
résoudre ça devient presque un événement
communal finalement à se déplacer comme
ça dans dans différentes lieux
absolument alors le déplace sur une
périphérie parce que il faut trimballer
les jambes puisqu'il y a des opus qui
s'enchaînent c'est-à-dire qu'on passe de
la chapelle à l'église par exemple en
l'espace de 30 minutes faut que les gens
se déplacent donc voilà il y a une
espèce de parcours comme ça rallye
rallye Beethoven et alors au mois de
l'adore faire ça très rapidement mais on
pourrait revenir justement dans une
prochaine émission au mois de juin il y
a également un événement avec des
établissements scolaires ah mais ça
c'est le ça fait un an que ça dure enfin
ça fait un an ça fait depuis de plus de
saison je sais pas pourquoi je me suis
pris de passion pour l'écologie sonore
alors on parle de la pollution de l'air
on parle de la pollution de l'eau on
parle de alors récemment je viens de
voir une émission sur la pollution
lumineuse donc ils sont en train de
faire des efforts et beaucoup de villes
qui sont en train de changer leur
éclairage
mais la pollution sonore on en parle
assez peu
pourquoi mystère au Canada ils sont très
en avance Belgique pas mal en Suisse ils
font des normes progrès en France on est
comme d'habitude assez en retard et vous
n'imaginez pas à quel point ça impacte
les populations les sociétés politiques
c'est le 17 juin s'il te plaît et ça
peut être vraiment un sujet complet
parce que alors je travaille avec 8
établissements scolaires quand même
c'est classe dont lui-même bailli avec
des handicapés et on travaille justement
sur
cette approche du paysage sonore enfin
c'est vrai on aura le temps on aura le
temps d'y revenir plus en détail puisque
c'est un sujet très très intéressant
merci beaucoup cette occasion on parlera
de mon départ voilà exactement
pour plus d'informations on peut se
rendre sur le site théâtre de Fontenay
de Fontenay pardon.fr et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]